Recall that a Turing machine always
starts in the initial state and
with its head over the first
position on the tape.
As it computes, its internal state,
the tape contents, and
the head position will change.
But everything else will stay the same.
We call this triple of state
tape content and head position,
a configuration.
And any given computation can be thought
of as a sequence of configurations.
It starts with the initial state,
the input string, and
with the head on the first location,
and it proceeds from there.
Now it isn't very practical to
always draw a picture like this
every time that we want to refer to
a computation of a Turing machine, so
we've developed some notation
that captures the idea.
Actually, we'll rewind
the computation we just did, and
do it again, this time writing down
the configuration using this notation.
We write the start
configuration as q01011.
The part to the left of this state
represents the tape contents to the left
of the head.
It's just the empty string,
in this case.
Then we have the state of the machine.
And then the rest of the tape contents.
After the first step,
a 1 is to the left of the head.
We're still in state q0, and
this is the rest of the string,
011, 011.
In the next configuration, 1,
0 is to the left of the head.
We're still in state q0 and 1,
1 is the rest of the tape content.
And so on and so forth.
This notation is a little awkward,
but it's convenient for type settings.
It's also very much in
the spirit of Turing machines,
where all structured data must
ultimately be represented as strings.
If a Turing machine can handle working
with data like this, then so can we.
At a slightly higher level, a whole
sequence of configurations like this
captures everything that a Turing
machine did on a particular input.
And so we will sometimes call
such a sequence a computation.
And actually this representation
of a computation will be central
as we discuss the Cool-Levin theorem
in the section on complexity.